welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Thanos estates in the MCU appear
to be over but that was also our
assumption with MCU villains like Red
Skull Zemo and Loki who appears to be
alive again in his own Disney Plus
series thanks to the Avengers time
Medlen and endgame resurrecting this god
of mischief on his own a branch timeline
from 2012 onward a branch timeline that
oh yeah also includes an alternate
Thanos perfectly alive and well still on
his quest for Infinity stones because
now that we're in a Marvel Cinematic
multiverse you know one guys in Evelynn
lives on forever and ever so whatever
issues Loki ends up in with the time
variance Authority you gotta imagine the
mad Titan who sent him to attack earth
and the Avengers is gonna want him to
answer for his failure Thanos just like
the MCU is Tony Soprano you can't get
away from that guy he's gonna find it
choking to death while touring colleges
with his daughter but as I have been
stuck quarantined in this blue dungeon
brie watching the Infinity Saga I
realized that Thanos's timeline from
2012 through endgame is very mysterious
if Marvel ever wanted to explore this
ultimate Thanos backstory there are a
lot of questions that they would need to
answer to let us break down
Thanos says new timeline the timeline
stuff Avengers endgame opened up the MCU
in all kinds of confusing ways but one
of the biggest points of confusion came
up with the alternate 2014 era Thanos
this is technically the one who died at
the end of the film when present-day
nebula and Rhodey go back to 2014 to get
the Power Stone for more AG we'd check
in briefly with nebula and Gamora from
that point in history they're mid-battle
and the endgame script actually revealed
their victims as korbinites the
horse-faced race of beta ray bill
suggested in the planet below them might
be corbin anyway 2014 gomorrah and 2014
nebula have an interesting exchange
father wants us back on the ship why
he's found an infinity stone
on a planet called Morag Father's plan
is finally in motion one stone is in six
nebulae it's a start this exchange is
setting up the history we saw in
guardians of the galaxy set in 2014 when
Thanos sent Ronan after the Power Stone
but the confusing part is they
specifically say fan of finding the
Power Stone is his first stone that
appears to contradict the events of the
first 2012 Avengers movie in which
Thanos sent Loki to earth for the
tesseract which contained the space
stone and we assume that Infinity stone
was the whole point of Loki's attack on
earth
additionally Loki's scepter at that
point contained another Infinity stone
the mind stone and the head cannon of
many of us was that they a no Slynt Loki
one Infinity stone so that look he could
use it to go get a second Infinity stone
you know and essentially an infinity
stone Double Down
but uh one that backfired but endgame
declares Thanos his first location of a
stone two years after that in 2014 so
the only way this makes sense is if
Thanos in 2012 did not yet know the
tesseract and Loki's scepter contained
Infinity stones in this case you could
imagine Thea knows searching the galaxy
for all kinds of powerful mystical
weapons but not sure which of those
weapons contained Infinity stones which
them didn't
so this interpretation of what Thanos
knew and when he knew it actually helps
explain the confusion around the gap in
Thanos his stone quest timeline and why
people like Thor didn't do more to stop
him so remember after guardians Thanos
the stone quest really kicked into gear
in the post-credits scene after age of
Ultron which showed him with an empty
Infinity Gauntlet vanos doesn't appear
again until the post-credits scene of
thor ragnarok kitchen thor with his
pants down but in age of Ultron Thor
experienced a vision showing him the
Infinity stones and that movie ended
with him supposedly setting off in
search of them so during that search why
didn't he run into Thanos why didn't he
at least know of what this was doing why
we see so surprised to see panis and
Ragnarok and infinity war our friend AJ
Essel however you see it brought up this
question on discord which all of you can
actually join that did square by begun
in the patron by the way and now there
are two points to make here first in
Ragnarok Thor does hint at some general
unrest around the galaxy but then I
decide to go out there and investigate
and what do I find
is completely in chaos enemies of Asgard
assembling plotting our demise fours
implication here is that Odin or should
we say Loki masquerading as Odin is
shirking his responsibility to provide
order insecurity across the realms and
as a result all kinds of enemies of
Asgard are making moves' enemies like
searcher like hella and sure like maybe
a big verbal [ __ ] named anos who has
over the past couple decades gained a
reputation as a psychopath
eco-terrorists amassing an army going
planet by planet calling them by half
but at the end of the day just one bad
actor in a galaxy full of [ __ ]
people like Thor might know who Fanus is
but he would have no reason to know that
Thanos's real plan was to find six
stones and carry out that dark vision
with just a snap now the second point is
that fan of with that empty gauntlet
I'll do it myself
that scene didn't necessarily take place
right after age of Ultron in 2015 if you
think about it it couldn't have because
an infinity war we learned that Thanos
got that gauntlet after sacking it of
Lear the forge that Thor was shocked to
find destroyed an infinity war years
later nineveh Lear is the primary armory
for Asgard if it got attacked it would
be like if a US military base got hit
and some nukes went missing people would
be freaking out the only way native lear
could have been attacked without Thor
knowing is if it happened during the
events of Ragnarok when Thor was
distracted stranded on SAC are fighting
hella on Asgard so that would put Thanos
his attack of 'native leer around 2017
and then he would put on the gauntlet
and go after the Power Stone ons and our
but why does Thanos wait that long why
doesn't he attack natively earlier after
Ronan let him down in guardians of the
galaxy in 2014 well we get this answer
in Thor Ragnarok Odin Odin is the key
here he is the badass power check of all
the nine realms but his death and
Ragnarok is what triggers all of the
chaos afterwards it allows hella
to return and it allows Thanos to
finally make his move many believe that
the additional right-handed gauntlet in
Odin's vaults wasn't just a joke he meta
Easter Egg it was a relic belonging to
Odin from his own past stone quest like
imagine Odin as a younger Asgardian God
was once on his own quest to gather all
six Infinity stones become master of the
universe but
ramier he was hit with a pang of guilt
for having to sacrifice the one he loved
the most
his daughter hella and in that misery he
decided to give up on the stone quest
and scattered the stones he had gathered
across the galaxy and their forward stop
anyone else from attempting to follow in
his footsteps and that lasted until his
death in 2017 think about a 20-17 was
also shortly after the time stone was
used on earth before dr. strange became
a mystic warrior the time stone remained
relatively hidden in the eye of agamotto
rarely if not never used but then
strange changed that all by using it to
defeat Dormammu an event with cosmic
reverberations that could have put a big
target on earth so in 2017 all the
pieces are now in place for Thanos he
knows which of the many powerful items
he sought our Infinity stones Odin's
death opens the door for him to attack
natively r2 get his own gauntlet and
then Thanos heads and arc for the Power
Stone all the while Thor is too busy
getting a haircut from Stanley to know
what's happening now this needs to just
be a past history that no longer really
mattered to the MCU but now that stories
like Loki are taking place in alternate
branch histories this pano stone quest
is still playing out in the background
of that branch history it could still
influence and collide with Loki's
journey
Bannos remains a deadly threat on a
mission with huge cosmic implications to
whatever universe he's alive in so don't
sleep on the mad Titan because even if
two versions of them are dead there are
infinite more of them to snap your neck
follow along our infinity saga re-watch
by joining our discord by becoming a
patron of new rock stars at patreon.com
slash and arrive stars comment down
below follow me Eddie a Vasa follow me
rock stars and subscribe to know rock
stars and breakdowns of everything you
love thanks for watching bye
[Music]